hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and we have a fun
one today it's a double poison pawn in
the french defense so the french starts
out with e4
e6 something i never like to see if i'm
playing e4 this is the french typically
continues with d4 and then d5
knight to c3 pretty common from whites
bishop to b4 this is the winner wear
variation i think it's pretty common for
black i do have a separate video if you
want to check out the winner where if
you're just interested in different
variations in the french defense but
after bishop here to b4 then the main
line is pawn to e5
black decides to respond with c5
typically in the french defense you're
going to see white attacking and
expanding on the king side of the board
black's looking to do the same thing on
the queen side so c5 does exactly that
opens up the queen side starts to chip
away at the center pawn here on d4
and white has really two main options
here knight to f3 is the main one but i
think another tricky option that
sometimes white will try is queen here
to g4 and you can see queen here on g4
is not only defending this pawn here on
d4 it's also attacking the pawn here on
g7
now this is a poison pawn and we'll
actually look at what happens if they
take that because black can give up
another pawn is a poison pawn
and this trap is actually something that
the best players in the world have
fallen into so 10 years ago magnus
carlson playing the white pieces fell
into this trap and you may say how ten
years ago was magnus carlsen that good
yes magnus carlson became the number one
player in the world
in 2011 so 10 years ago he was winning
literally every tournament he was
playing
he fell for this trap and ended up
losing so it is a good one and hopefully
after this video you will think so as
well
black is going to continue with knight
to e7 and this is really laying the trap
so you're not going to just play
something like pawn to g6 that may look
like it's stopping the queen coming down
here to g7
which it is but it's not really setting
a trap so knight to
e7 makes it look like okay yes you
almost have to move the knight or the
pawn because if not then the queen could
just come down here on g7 and then
easily take the rook so it almost looks
like the knight's just moving out of the
way so that the rook is not going to be
taken very easily and potentially just
doesn't want to play g6 so
white many times we'll just go ahead and
take that pawn here on g7 black's going
to play rook to
g8 you know the rook is under attack so
pretty much has to move but now white
can just easily take this pawn here on
h7 and this is the trap because
if white takes these two pawns yes black
cannot castle on the king side anymore
that's completely okay
black is going to have a very good game
here because they have a lot of threats
and the first threat is the pawn taking
here on d4 this knight here on c3 is
being pinned
to the king by the bishop here on b4
so that is the first threat here that
white can just
lose the knight here on c3 with the pawn
taking here so how does white really
respond to this well if you look at
something like pawn to a3
this attacks the bishop well okay this
gets tricky because the move queen to a5
and this just says yeah if you want to
take my bishop that's fine
because now we can just come down here
and take with our queen here on
a1
and now we're also threatening to move
queen takes here on c1 they can't move
their bishop because it's being pinned
down by the queen so really they move
they need to move them knight to e2 for
two reasons one it's defending this
bishop here on c1 but also it's being
attacked by this pawn here on
d4 so if you look at this setup
all of a sudden white lost the rook here
on a1 not exactly what they want to
their knight on e2 is kind of stuck
because it's defending the bishop the
bishop can't move it's pinned down
because this knight's here this light
square bishop on f1 is not going
anywhere
the knight on g1 definitely can get out
so that's a move that white has here
and black's pretty well defended the
queen over here on h7 is kind of hanging
out by themselves and so black can
really do exactly what they want they
can get their other pieces involved into
the game
knight to b6 if they want or c6 if they
want to that's going to attack both the
pawn here on e5 as well as the pawn here
on b4 they can get their bishop involved
into the games they can start to push up
the other pawns here on the b file and
the a file so black has a lot of threats
here and it's going to be very difficult
for black to continue if we come back
maybe they decide okay probably not the
best idea to just take right there
so let's get the
the rook out of harm's way let's go
ahead and play
rook to b1 okay well in this case we go
ahead and take the knight here on c3 as
we talked about
they take our bishop
but then we can play queen to a2
now this is still threatening the rook
and the rook is going to fall any time
they take and they leave open this a
file we're just going to come down and
eventually take their rook here
so now they could play rook to e2
we're going to take their rook here on
b1
pawn takes here on c3 that's completely
fine
and then we can play something like
knight to d7 different ways of how you
want to get the knight involved into the
game but
this threatens this
pawn here on uh e5 it also allows if we
wanted to to get the knight to come back
here to f8 and have some protection in
there as well so a couple options uh
from white there but you can see black
even has more material here because
we're able not only to take that knight
but we're also able to take that rook
okay so let's come back we've already
looked at the fact that if they
don't play pawn to a3
then we're pretty much just going to
take with our pawn here on c3 they're
going to lose the knights
that's going to be pretty difficult
and so a3 makes some sense to attack the
bishop here but then we have the threat
of queen to a5 and they can't really
take with their pawn here
because then we're just going to take
their rook so what if they decide to
just leave that alone and start to
develop material on the king side of the
board recognizing they really have to
get material out start
to attack
black at some capacity or else they're
just going to get suffocated and lose so
maybe knight to f3
black's always going to take that knight
here on c3 with the pawn
pawn to b3 i think is the best move from
white if you look at the threats that
black has after the pawn takes here it's
a discovered attack that bishop is now
going to check the king and then white's
going to lose either the bishop or the
rook so i really think that white almost
has to play b3 if not they're definitely
going to lose material here
then black plays knight to d7
because
white does have the threat now of bishop
here to
d3
preparing to come over and attack here
on the king side of the board also they
need to be opening up to castle on the
king side to get some sort of safety
here
but now we can just come down take the
pawn here on g2 that's one thing to keep
in mind as soon as they play bishop here
to d3
we're just eyeing down and we can just
take this material here on g2
they could play knight to g5 threatening
something like queen takes here on f7
that would be
very bad for black
we can just go ahead and take the rook
yes we gave up a
rook
for a knight and a pawn but that's going
to be completely okay as far as the
situation that we have to worry about
here so after the bishop takes we can
now play knight to c6 this is attacking
this pawn right here we still have a lot
of threats they still can't take with
their pawn right here because we could
just take their rook up here
and they're going to have a difficult
time now you do have to be very cautious
from black standpoint because you have a
weakened king
there's not a lot of protection here the
knight here on d7 it's going to do a
good job of coming down here to f8 if it
needs to protect from the queen at some
point
but this is going to be very dynamic
from both sides and you can see that at
any given move
either side can fall apart but i do
think black has a good position in this
setup so that is
the double poison pawn trap so if we
come back it's it's really not the best
move for white to go ahead and take
this pawn here on g7 and if they do take
where it comes over here to g8
i think it gets even trickier if they
decide to take this pawn here on h7 they
could just come back to h6 the main
reason that queen two h6 is better is
let's just continue down the same lines
we're looking at pawn takes here on d4
this knight's being pinned down so play
a3 as we talked about queen two a5 but
now they can take and after we take the
rook here on a1
now you can see that this queen is
protecting the bishop now before they
pretty much had to play knight to e2
because that was not only
the knights being under attack so it has
to move
and if they move anywhere else the
bishop's not defended so the queen could
just come here to see one it's gonna
fall there's nowhere else because it's
being pinned
but because the queen is actually
protecting it's on these dark squares
then like it's free to actually go
somewhere else so then i can come here
to b5 it's attacking the pawn here on d4
it's also no longer blocking off this
light square bishop so it's going to be
much better for white if they don't
actually fall for the double poison pawn
trap
just go ahead and take that one poison
pawn i still think they're going to be
in a tough spot you can see the queen's
not going anywhere it's very easy for
black to get their own knight involved
into the game put a lot of pressure on
the opponent you know even just pushing
forward with both the pawns yes you do
lose your central pawn here
but as soon as the slice square bishop
moves black and come up take this
material here on g2 so a lot of stuff
that white has to deal with but i think
it's a much better position
if they play queen here to h6 than
taking the extra pawn here on h7 so that
is the double poison pawn trap hopefully
you guys enjoyed this video hope you
learned something hopefully if you like
playing the french you can lay this trap
for someone and they can fall on it
if you are playing as white and you run
up against this hopefully now you know
how to avoid
the worst lines possible so thank you
guys so much for watching the video i'll
see you guys in the next one